this story is just it
it is so demonstrative of everything
that the left has become
it truly is an amazing thing so patton
oswalt is a wild leftist crazy person
he is a standup comic who is most famous
for voicing the rat in ratatouille
and uh and he
is he's still doing some stand-up kind
of stuff again everything that he does
is wildly to the left pat and oswald so
on new year's eve he was doing a comedy
club and in the comedy club next door
was dave chappelle
and so he took a picture with dave
chappelle and he put a post on instagram
and said finished my set at mccall hall
and got a text from dave chappelle come
over to the arena he's performing it
next door into a guest set why not i
waved goodbye to this hell year with a
genius i started comedy with 34 years
ago he works in arena like he's talking
to one person and charming their skin
off anyway i ended the year with a real
friend and a deep laugh can't ask for
much more oh it's a nice way to end the
year isn't that nice there's only one
problem of course patton oswald is of
the left and dave chappelle has offended
the alphabet people as he likes to say
he's offended the trans activists who
have suggested that he's a very very bad
evil bad man for noting that men and
women exist
so patton oswalt then had to reverse
himself because cowards don't get killed
they get their friends killed cowards
are the people who ensure that their
friends are the ones thrown under the in
fact they help with throwing under the
bus i hope that dave chappelle goes to
war with pat and oswald i desperately
hope it because patton oswalt deserves
it so he put up a picture
that i just have to describe for you for
a moment it is a picture of patton
oswalt
sitting in front of a yellow legal pad
his headphones plugged into his his
phone
staring at himself in the mirror or at
least looking down and then the pictures
of him in a mirror because he's he's
really you know he's he's doing some
introspection
so the glor
the utter narcissism a picture of him
with another image of him in the mirror
both of whom are staring down at the
pence at the pad of paper where they are
writing their forced apology maoist
maoist struggle session note quote
i saw a friend i hadn't seen in a long
time this new year's eve we've known
each other since we're teens he's a
fellow comedian the funniest i've ever
met i wanted to post a pic and an
instagram story about it so i did the
friend is dave chappelle 34 years we've
been friends he's refocused and refined
ideas a lot of us took a settled about
race and history and life on planet
earth and spun them around with a phrase
or a punchline we've done bad and good
gigs open mics and tv tapings but we
also 100 disagree about transgender
rights and representation i support
trans people's rights anyone's rights to
live safely in the world as their
fullest selves for all the things he's
helped me evolve on i'll always disagree
with where he stands now on transgender
issues but i also don't believe a secret
like him is done evolving learning you
know someone that long see the struggles
and changes it's impossible to cut them
off impossible not to be hopeful and
open and cheer them on also i've been
carrying a lot of guilt about friends
i've cut off who had views with which i
couldn't agree or changed in ways i
couldn't live with sometimes i wonder
did i and others cutting them off make
them dig their heels in deeper fuel
their ignorance with a nitro boost of
resentment in spite
i'm in lgbtq plus ia open bracket close
bracket tilde
little
little equals sign ally i'm a loyal
friend there's a friction in those
traits that i need to reconcile myself
and not let cause feels of betrayal in
anyone else
and i'm sorry truly sorry that i didn't
consider the hurt this would cause or
the depth of that hurt i've been
messaging a lot on ig today and the back
and forth has really helped guide me in
the writing of this i naively deleted a
lot of posts in the comment thread
critical ones from lgbtq writers and
bleep post by turf anti-trans orcs
looking for clicks and giggles i wanted
a nice comment thread about to pick with
my friend ugh so easy to think someone
else needs growth and miss the need in
yourself gonna keep trying
oh isn't that nice but he's not really
talking about the growth of himself most
of that post is about how dave chappelle
needs to grow and change and the only
reason he's staying friends with dave
chappelle is because he hopes that dave
chappelle will one day come to embrace
his own views so this is not him saying
i can embrace a friend who disagrees
with me on this issue this isn't saying
the only reason i embrace this friend is
because one day he will embrace my views
on this issue which by the way is the
opposite of friendship
okay if the idea is that you can only be
friends with people who agree with you
on everything
or people who you believe that you will
eventually convince to agree with you on
everything that does not seem like
somebody that should be friends with you
because what if 10 years from now they
look around and dave chappelle still
feels the same way that he does today
because by the way dave chappelle is
correct
is patton oswald then gonna cut him off
right now his excuses i still think i
can make a difference with it i can save
dave i can make dave finn lgbtq plus i a
open carrot
british pound sign ampersand ally and
because of that i'm still gonna be
friends with dave but if he can't well
then isn't he obligated to throw dave
under the bus
and isn't that really what he's doing
right now he's saying that the reason
that he's friends with dave is because
he's superior to dave
this is so much of the virtue signaling
right it is it is all about for people
like patent oswald it is all about
signaling to everyone that they are
better than you he's so introspective
he's so thoughtful he's so he's so
wonderful right he's he's right on the
issues and he's broad-minded enough to
know that his stupid friend doesn't
believe what he believes and that one
day his stupid friend may come to
believe what he believes and that's why
he's sorry that he took a picture with
that friend and didn't note in there
that his friend also is a bigot a
vicious wild bigot but he should still
be friends with him
man i hope that dave chappelle just
wrecks him because no one deserves it
more than the rat man patton oswalt my
goodness
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video